la politique qu'avec les élections
départementales et régionales c'est dans
moins de deux mois maintenant et des
candidats confrontés un double casse
tête
l'interdiction des meetings et le
désintérêt des électeurs focaliser sur
le commis 19
alors comment font-ils campagne c'est
notre carnet de campagne ce soir ellen
chapelet a suivi deux candidats aux
régionales en indre et loire et loir et
cher vous allez le voir le bon vieux
téléphone est re devenu un allié de
poids
ils sont tous les deux candidats aux
régionales de juin prochain
à droite christine fauqué élu régional
dans l'opposition depuis 2010 à gauche
charles fournier vice-président en
charge de la transition écologique tous
les deux doivent faire campagne dans un
contexte sanitaire compliqué alors
comment font-ils
à 61 ans christine fauqué n'est pas une
novice en politique
maire de saint règle une petite commune
à côté d'amboise elles siègent dans
l'opposition au conseil régional depuis
2010 aujourd'hui elle postule à un
troisième mandat sur la liste de la
droite et du centre du député nicolas
forissier et pour elle l'un des premiers
défis de cette campagne c'est de
parvenir à intéresser et mobiliser les
électeurs
à l'heure actuelle les gens c'est pas ça
qui les intéresse ils veulent savoir où
en est l'épidémie si vous êtes vacciné
est-ce que je vais pas perdre mon emploi
enfin voilà les préoccupations mais
après c'est la région qui gère ça
donc voilà il faut arriver à faire
comprendre aux gens que précisément
c'est maintenant qu'il faut voter pour
pour des équipes régionales qui leur
conviennent 1 quelle qu'elle soit mais
qu'il faut c'est déplacez voter et voter
en indre et loire 18 candidats doivent
être désignés par les urnes pour siéger
au conseil régional
ils seront dix en provenance du
loir-et-cher et charles fournier espère
être de ceux là
le blésois de 53 ans connaît déjà
l'hémicycle orléanais il y siège en tant
qu'élu depuis 2010
aujourd'hui il est le chef de file d'une
liste regroupant neuf parties dont
europe ecologie les verts et la france
insoumise
pour cette campagne inédite il souhaite
s'adresser de manière encore plus
personnelle à chaque électeur
les gens sont chez eux sont confinés ne
viennent pas dans les salles
alors nous allons vers les gens et pour
aller vers les gens vous adresser des
messages plus directe des emails des
appels téléphoniques des messages vidéo
donc on utilise beaucoup plus des formes
plus individualisé plus personnalisé
pour réussir à convaincre que notre
projet est celui qu'il faut choisir
évidemment au premier tour des élections
régionales en 2015 50 % des inscrits de
la région centre ne s'étaient pas
déplacés pour glisser leur bulletin dans
l'urne
qu'en sera-t-il le 20 juin prochain la
réponse sera sans doute lié à
l'évolution de l'épidémie